I was recently diagnosed with Grover's disease. Grover's disease has nothing to do with the
muppet character. It's a skin rash typically in older men where you get this itchy, extreme,
itchy flares just as this person is saying they're looking for a rife program for this.
I like to look at what you really want to look at is for this is antihistamines.
So if you look up Grover's disease, you won't find anything that is the known cause. However,
Grover's disease along with many other skin rashes that have no known causes that are idiopathic
are due to histamine reactions due to exposure of toxins. So with a person that has had cancer,
you're exposed. I think this person just in surgery, you're exposed to chemicals in the,
you're exposed to tons of garbage they had to put you up with chemicals, you report out with
the drugs, you know, those things build up in your system and you end up with a histamine reaction
due to those things. So it's all gets back to detoxification pathways going back to the seven phases
of detox. Think about antihistamine-type things and remember for a cancer patient, you know,
there's some drugs that can be good for a cancer patient and one of them is the antihistamine
over the counter antihistamines. So over the counter antihistamine, if it helps with this, it can,
it will also help decrease histamines elsewhere in your body, which can be really good for
your cancer. So think about other good natural antihistamines, large bark gum, corset and any
anti-inflammatory things. That's what I would think of. Also, you can do things on your skin to give
you relief. I would think of things like some, we have some new tallow-based creams that can be
really good. I would use a tallow. You could also try a coconut oil, you could try like a comfrey
based sand, maybe you mix that with a tallow. I would try different things that will decrease
the inflammation. But almost always, I mean, one of these that may help with this is doing the
soluna. So you have to test that out. I would do, if you have a soluna, do short period of
times of the soluna, that could help with that too.